they thought they had found the Fountain  of money right there is nothing more  lucrative than a license to print money  this is why the Bitcoin Maximus just get  so angry right they declare war on the  [ __ ] coiners and coinery the idea that  you can just create your own token sell  it to the general public and manipulate  the price of it and dump it on but but  here's where the poor Bitcoin has never  figured out their view is they're  creating a coin and dumping it on retail  but again Sam's Twist on it was no I'm  not going to dump it on retail I'm  driving into the sky I'm never gonna  sell it I'm going to use it to buy other  Banks and then I'm going to drain the  assets out of the bank by giving myself  an under the table loan it's so much  more diabolical than just dumping a coin  on unsuspecting retail Traders so yeah  he did it